today the EU has trade agreements in
place with many countries people often
believe these deals only benefit big
international companies but they
actually help more small businesses than
you might think
take a firm like manufacturer it
produces traditional handmade pottery in
Bali suave eats in Poland company owner
Pavel spheres wanted to export to South
Korea where the type of pottery his
business makes is very popular
unfortunately high import duties make
this hard or Aaron lay on a winery from
Valencia in Spain that specializes in
organic wines this type of wine isn't
much in demand in Spain but it's highly
sought-after in Canada the problem was
certain rules that Canada had put in
place these made it harder for imports
of alcoholic drinks from Europe to
compete on the Canadian market there's
also reclaim a German recycling company
it wants to export its know-how to the
Canadian province of British Columbia
where one firm holds a monopoly on
recycling reclaim Obul strategy manager
Adrian Verner is convinced more
competition could create new export
opportunities for reclaim and cut local
recycling costs in half
if only reclaim was allowed onto the
market by lifting trade barriers EU
trade deals have benefited all three
companies as well as their employees
their families and even their
communities look at manufacturer today
following a trade deal with South Korea
a third of its ceramics are now sold
there its workforce has gone from 10 to
213 employees and a new pottery museum
in Bali suave eats welcomes 10,000
tourists a year from around the world
just think how many enjoy a drink or a
meal in one of the local restaurants at
Aaron Leone company owner Maria Sancho
also has plenty of reasons to be
cheerful in 2015 her firm sold 100,000
bottles of wine in Canada making it the
largest distributor of organic wine in
the province of Quebec once a new trade
deal between the EU and Canada is up and
running
Canadian wine lovers might get even
more of a taste for Spanish wines and
all of those empty bottles could provide
extra work for recycling companies like
replay the upcoming trade deal between
the EU and Canada will break down even
more barriers for European companies and
could make it possible for reclaim it
for public contracts in Canada these are
just three examples of the many small
companies across Europe that EU trade
deals have helped or Russ set to do so
and helping them matters more than
600,000 small businesses in the EU
export outside Europe and over 30
million jobs across Europe depend on
exports outside the EU find out more
about how the EU helps small businesses
export successfully ECE Europa you slash
trade